[Musik]
zum einbrennen des Fahrzeugs die vordere
Feuerwehr an sowie
okay
[Musik]
eingetroffen beginnt mit Löscharbeiten
die patrolet fordert über das
Kompanie an die alarmiert den der
kombinationszug welcher dann zum Einsatz
Zug errichtet im Nahbereich einen
personalisationsplatz welche die drei
Hauptgruppen
[Musik]
für die Kombination vorbereitet den
eigentlichen kombinationsplatz sowie den
[Musik]
die Gruppe die zuvor den Brand des
Fahrzeuges abgehandelt hat und sich
dabei kontaminiert hat hat nun den
Personen dekonominationsplatz erreicht
am personenisationsplatz durchläuft die
Person mehrere Stationen angefangen von
Abgabe der Ausrüstung bis hin zur
Abnahme der Schutzmaske der persönlichen
Begleitung sowie am Ende zur ganzkörper
nasse
[Musik]